-Well, finally, this weekend,
NBC has another big
Sunday Night Football game,
with the Bears
taking on the Chargers.
It's very exciting.
Everyone's buzzing about it.
People are buzzing
about this football.
In fact, there's a song
out right now
called "NBC Sunday Night"...
-Really?
...that's currently number one
on the Euro dance charts.
-I didn't know that.
-Yeah.
And the video
just dropped today.
-Really?
-Well, take a look at this.
[ Electro-pop music plays ]
-♪ La da da, dee dee da,
da da, da da ♪
-♪ NBC Sunday Night ♪
♪ NBC craziness ♪
-♪ La da da, dee dee da,
da da, da da ♪
-♪ NBC Sunday Night ♪
♪ NBC football ♪
♪ Hike the ball,
pass the ball ♪
♪ Run the ball,
please protect ♪
♪ See the ball,
catch the ball ♪
♪ Steal the ball,
intercept ♪
♪ Sunday night comes along ♪
♪ Football night,
nothing's wrong ♪
♪ Staying short or going long ♪
♪ It's the Sunday Night
Football song ♪
-♪ La da da, dee dee da,
da da, da da ♪
-♪ NBC Sunday night ♪
♪ NBC craziness ♪
-♪ La da da, dee dee da,
da da, da da ♪
-♪ NBC Sunday night ♪
♪ NBC football ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amazing! Number one
on the Euro dance.
My thanks to Charli D'Amelio
for helping us out with that.